una ciudad que desapareció por la furia
de la naturaleza la Brian Knight camina
por los escombros de Rolling fork una
pequeña ciudad al oeste de Mississippi
con menos de 2000 habitantes aquí nació
y creció y este fin de semana él y su
familia sobrevivieron al poder de un
tornado F4 uno de los más violentos Y
destructivos del que se tenga registro
las luces se apagaron y oí un gran
sonido las ventanas volaron los
escombros nos golpeaban
el servicio meteorológico nacional en
Jackson Mississippi informó que el
tornado permaneció en tierra durante
aproximadamente una hora y abrió una
Estela de destrucción de unos 274
kilómetros
puedes ver ese camión allí es de mi
hermano es camionero todos esos camiones
de ahí son sus camiones
[Música]
el momento más aterrador de mi vida fue
aterrador pensé que no íbamos a
sobrevivir porque este árbol de ahí
estaba en realidad en nuestro patio
trasero si hubiera pasado por encima de
la mitad trasera de la casa
probablemente no estaría aquí sentada
hablando contigo
el presidente Joe biden aprobó la
declaración de emergencia para el Estado
de Mississippi un mecanismo que
permitirá a los locales acceder a
subvenciones para alojamiento Temporal y
reparaciones de viviendas pese a la
rápida respuesta el peligro aún no
termina el centro de predicciones de
tormentas del servicio meteorológico
nacional advirtió que Mississippi
Alabama aún podrían enfrentar fuertes
vientos granizo y posibles tornados